in case you can't remember what we did
was I took this and I said okay what is
this look like because the whole point
was absolute value graphs right but some
of you understandably said I'm still not
quite there with grass yet which is fine
so what's the other way right because
I've been saying graphing is one way but
it's not there anyway so let me show you
the other way right so this algebraic
now another way you say algebraically is
by cases okay so you might hear that
phrase sometimes and this is what it's
referring to
he is the way I'm going to break it down
do you remember the start of the lesson
I showed you this I showed you this
right so I said look the absolute value
of x it's equal to this sometimes and
this other times and then I said why you
have to value Y is equal to this
sometimes and this other times I'm gonna
reply exactly the same scenario but I'm
gonna okay with these two okay and
that's gonna once I do that that will
give me the cases that I will then solve
it so watch absolute value of X minus 1
okay sometimes it's equal to this okay
so this is me say in the negative case
so I say when that thing inside the
bracket is negative that's when you slap
a minus sign when X minus 1 is negative
okay that's a bit of awqaf when you're
saying I would like to sit domain that
just says X's is greater than this or
less than this and that's fine so I'm
just gonna muck around me this a little
bit X is less than 1 there you go
that's where that's the condition I
apply for when this is true okay
alternatively and just equal to this
when X minus 1 is positive zero doesn't
matter as you can see right so this is
when X is greater than equal 1 okay
I have two cases for that guy three
cases when you come down to hear you
play it in exactly the same way I'm
going to be equal to the name
- case - 2 X - 4
when's that thing inside the brackets is
less than 0 okay now you will start to
get to the point where you do not have
to go through all of these lines of
working where you'll be able to see
right away oh it's X is less than
negative 2 right in a similar to similar
way - if you guys see this you don't um
an R and think all what are the zeros
you just read them off you say negative
3 & 2 because you've seen these so many
times you start to do the same thing
with this it's a very similar kind of
situation let me take a shortcut and say
okay once I know where the negative case
is true
I also right away know where the
positive case is true because it's just
the other side of the inequality so it's
equal to that when X is greater than
okay now I said I was gonna do this
algebraically and I'm going to cheat
just a little bit because I do have to a
boy life cell I have to draw a line okay
why am I gonna do this right you might
think oh when I've got two cases here
and two cases here when I combine them
when I combine the maestra gift for
cases which is exactly what happened
here right but because all of this is
just in one variable right it's just in
X you don't actually get four cases you
only get three watch here my brother's
there's one in the boundary okay and
negative two is abandoned so think about
this okay think about what happens when
X is less than or equal to negative two
right which of these cases are we in
that one right that's the case we're in
and in which of these cases are we in
we're in this one okay so I'm gonna call
that case one okay case one is when I
combine these two what about between
negative two and one
which cases am i doing well I'm greater
than negative
to sum this one but I'm still less than
one I'm still here right so now I
combine these two right so between these
values I'm going to call that case two
and then lastly you can see when X is
greater than one I've already switched
over to this one right because I passed
negative two over here right so I'm in
this one and now across limit of this
value right so this is for X is greater
than equal to one
I'm gonna call that case three okay
there are three cases and now I just go
through them one at a time
right case one okay now when I said X is
less than or equal to negative two which
of these am I on this one X is less than
negative two right so therefore you
let's try another way of thinking about
this is they're both the negative case
so here's the first negative case and
then here is the other negative case and
that's equal to five okay
maybe okay state your case and now I
just solve this is algebra
yeah I've just I've written that there
so that I'm gonna so this is my diagram
to tell me what my cases are I could
write it again if you like like so okay
help me solve it help me solve it
collect some like terms over here for me
what am I gonna get okay
you're 11 I've had a look and I've been
listening as well because well he's not
that bad and I'm pretty sure all the
conversations happening right now a good
conversation and I want them to continue
I just want them to continue at a volume
that lets the people who are trying to
listen to this listen to it does that
make sense
cool let's keep going all I'm doing over
here is unjust solving over break which
looks to me like that which looks to me
like this which is a very familiar
number okay now check that here's the
important thing about cases right this
thing is totally true this isn't what
the absolute values are equal to only
where this is true right so you look at
this and you say does this lie within
our restricted domain is is minus 2 and
2/3 is it less than or equal to negative
2 and the answer is yes it is so that's
the solution
thumbs up rinse and repeat
case 2 okay you're gonna put all the
algebra together but watch now I'm
between here and here right so I am here
I'm greater than negative 2 notes but
I've cross over to still here right so
this one's changed over to the positive
case but this one's still the negative
case right so case 2 will be negative x
plus 1 plus and now I have crossed over
to this one and that's equal to 5 okay
again you go through the algebra here
I'm gonna get X plus 5 equals 5 so x
equals 0 you look at that you check is
the solution I've got him is it in my
restricted domain and the answer is yes
it is tick it's a solution final case
case 3 okay now both of them are in the
positive case right so this is kind of
easy to write I just say X minus 1/2 X
plus 4 that's equal to 5 3 X let's see 3
5 take that over to that side you divide
through and just like we have with all
the other cases you look at this you say
is this within the restricted domain
that I've defined and you say oh I'm not
I should be greater than or equal to 1
but this is not so this is not a
solution this is an extraneous solution
right so now I've gone through all my
cases I've worked out which assertions
overlap valid and which ones aren't
and so I say therefore X is negative 2 0
and that's it so it's a very blunt tool
because you can't know which cases are
gonna be right or not until you get to
the very end of solving the algebra
right which by the way this is not too
bad that in this game who petechiae a
lot messier than this so can you imagine
going through 1 2 3 4 5 5 plus lines of
working that are taking you time and are
ways where errors can be introduced to
get to the point you say oh guess what
all that work you just did doesn't
matter because your answers not valid
anymore ok so if you do it graphically
right from memory it looks something
like this let's see and then my line 5
went yeah yes oh my god
it went through like that so I'm looking
for points of intersection I say 1 2 and
now I know immediately which branches
which corresponds to we
cases I need to solve and I can just
take it on this guy because I know that
he's not going to give me a solution
okay